guys i've been inside the closet
for days but i think i
i think i found a way
what there's so much space here
marzia you're in here as well
damn we have a lot of unused storage
space
there's another door inside the closet
where does this go
what what
this is so spacious mindset
can you believe what this has been
inside old
we can store so much okay
something is definitely wrong here
why is there a completely different city
in my closet
this is epic guys
all right it's getting annoying now all
right we're on holiday
i think we're in budapest and
it's pretty it's pretty epic
what do you think marzia she says
i like it it looks so pretty yeah
it's it's a city okay so now we're going
to
gillard spa which is like a thermal bath
spa
thing very nice all right this is the
part where
usually you would add just background
music
like any other vlogger but in i can't be
bothered
to find the right fitting track and sync
it all up so here you go here's some
footage of
hungary there's a boat went pretty fast
i thought i'd film it
there's a girl that waved at me at the
ferry and i tried a way back and
realized i just
ruined the shot but here you go that's
it that's a nicer one
all right um budapest is very pretty
very pretty buildings and stuff but
where are all the bit i don't
i didn't mean it so we're going there
very nice oh you see the pool
very nice i doubt i'm able to film
but i'm probably going to do it anyway
lp style
so pretty damn
look at this very nice
all right let's try it out i'm going in
it's nice and high happy anniversary
look how beautiful thanks
amazing this is the outdoor area
there you go everybody
now you've seen it
what would you rate the best i liked it
i would give it an
eight out of ten maybe even a night
what that's pretty good what would you
do
i don't rate things that's not what i do
okay but it was good
all right we're checking out this um
castle it's literally right here
there you go everybody hope you enjoy
that i would rate it i want
i mean good morning it's another day in
hungary
and guess what we're hungry
there's a national holiday today so
we're told it's going to be very
busy and loud wish it is
[Applause]
[Music]
he coming down oh he's falling
this is the parliament
this is the line to enter what is this
tanacon no
thank you child
hello everybody this is me reporting in
i am now on a bicycle as you can see
will be updated oh i got right now hey
really nice uh fans here in hungary
everyone's been really cool and chill
i like it this is everything else is a
mess
we're going to put a castle now
reporting
there oh my god
we have to go through there
maybe the bikes wasn't the best idea
okay so we're in the line to
go up there to get to the buddha castle
i'm really glad i'm wearing all black
really good choice
because i'm not high at all
looks like we got a cameo in this vlog
here we are guys
in the cabin
all right beautiful shot of budapest
it's uh there oh there we go there's a
first bridge
for all the idiots that walked up
yeah all right
and then um there's the other bridge
for all the morons they decided that you
were gonna walk up that hill
losers and there's how it looks like
going down it was
it was okay i guess i like this statue
it was very epic it looks way better in
person
um and there's a kid
i don't know why i'm filming these i
just thought it would be nice
[Music]
okay
it's only been more busier how is it
possible
this is crazy
[Music]
we're now joining the parade my sis
actually really wanted to
so i'm looking forward i'm not looking
in the camera
it makes okay there's nothing wrong with
my eyes don't worry
maybe our restaurant is over
what is happening what is this they are
basically
we have no choice you can't see me
that's cool you can see the top of my
head that's all you need to see
here i am oh it was better without it
was better with that
oh you're taking a picture we're waiting
for the fireworks to start
they're supposed to start everyone is
talking about the fireworks
they start in 10 minutes are you excited
yeah oh no that's my face i don't know
i say i'm doing it wrong okay marcy i
figured it out
oh no i missed it oh my god it's a halo
theme
it's coming
[Music]
it's going crazy
wow
oh
congratulations hungary for your
independence
well done you deserve it good morning
last day in budapest
we're back on the bikes and uh we're
going to
the market yay
these bikes are really bad it's really
hard to cycle
and considering how it went yesterday
i'm amazed that we're still on it
there it is
[Music]
how to be a real hungarian get a cool
hat
let's say do you want to get one
it has come in it yeah
okay
oh my god
she just gave it to me he's so awesome
yeah his
hands are so awesome look at it
[Applause]
[Music]
oh you can't go there
oh no oh no oh my god so cute
[Music]
cute
sorry
all right that was really cool bit
random
we're going to eat lunch now in case
anyone is curious what we're doing
nice walk away from me all right so now
we're going to eat lunch
i really look forward to it and uh
it's going to be great
what is this
one thing about budapest is that taxi
drivers will not take you anywhere
they told us they don't want to go
because he doesn't want to turn around
first he thought we were going somewhere
else and i insisted like no we're not
going there we're going over there and
he's like well
i don't want to go there and i'm like
why i don't want to turn
that's yeah me
this is me oh my god this is me
said this is so me
this is totally me right now plants
plants
plants demonetized plants plants
all right we are here in the place
this is where the shoes are look at that
there's so many shoes
so these are from uh the war with people
leaving notes in them
living candles and it's been a really
nice trip
very nice very fine trip i would say
what do you think mine is again
it was great
all right that's it for the budapest
vlog hope you guys enjoyed it leave a
like if you did
we're taking the plane back now in
a few hours wait
that's it there's a portal in here
i see i see the bedroom
i see oh my god there's something here
marzian come with